i will first call the prime minister to
answer the engagements question and then
we'll call kim johnson so prime minister
your engagement
thank you mr speaker it will be three
years tomorrow
since a chemical weapon was deployed by
russian military intelligence on the
streets of salisbury
all our thoughts remain with those
affected their families
and loved ones and we will continue to
seek justice for them
mr speaker i'm sure this house will want
to pay tribute to the people of
salisbury and amesbury
and wish them well for the future mr
speaker this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues
and others in addition to my duties in
this house i shall have further such
meetings later today
i said to kim johnson kim
thank you mr speaker liverpool is a
welcoming city the oldest
chinese community in europe but in 1946
the british government ordered the
forced repatriation
of thousands of chinese seamen living in
liverpool with their british families
back to china
causing lasting emotional trauma many of
those who sent and still live in my
liverpool riverside constituency
will the prime minister take steps to
acknowledge these events
and provide the descendants with the
formal apology and
for the justice they deserve thank you
mr speaker
because i've had happy memories of my
own uh
visits uh to liverpool and i can tell
her that
uh i i can tell her that uh we are
certainly very grateful across the
country to the
uh chinese community for their amazing
uh contribution and her message has been
heard
loud and clear right let's head to john
stevenson john
thank you mr speaker the prairie factory
in carlisle employs around 800 people
contributes hundreds of millions of
pounds to local economy
and is an exporter its location is a
consequence of regional economic policy
from 50 years ago
would the prime minister agree that if
we are to rebalance the economy
level up the country we need a modern
day proactive
regional economic policy and if he does
agree
will he come to carlisle to see the old
and new in action
of course mr speaker uh i'm very
grateful to my honourable friend for
uh for what he says and he will hear
more in just
half an hour or so let's try and keep it
to half an hour
uh mr speaker uh from the chancellor
about how exactly we intend to make sure
we build that better across the whole of
this country
and and unleash the tremendous potential
of the whole of the united kingdom
including
of course carlisle which he so well
represents
the leader of the opposition kirsten
thank you mr speaker can i join the
prime minister in his comments about the
salisbury atrocity
does the prime minister agree with
president biden that the sale of arms
that could be used in the war in yemen
should be suspended uh
mr speaker ever since the uh tragic
conflict in
uh yemen broke out this country has
scrupulously followed the
uh consolidated guidance of which uh uh
he will be well aware
the trouble is that whilst president
biden has suspended arms sales that
could be used in yemen
the uk hasn't in fact we sold 1.4
billion pounds of arms to saudi arabia
in the last
in three months last year including
bombs and missiles that could be used in
yemen
given everything we know about the
appalling humanitarian cost of this war
with innocent civilians caught between
the saudi coalition
and the houthi rebels why does the prime
minister think it's right
to be selling these weapons
mr speaker the uk is part of a an
international
uh coalition following the uh un
resolutions
which uh he will know well uh which
are very clear that the legitimate
government
of yemen was removed illegally
those are the resolutions that we we
follow and we continue scrupulously to
follow
the humanitarian guidance which are
amongst the toughest measures anywhere
in the world
in respect of all arms sales he talks
about uh humanitarian
relief mr speaker and actually i think
the people of this country can be hugely
proud
of what we are doing to support the
people of yemen
almost 1 billion pounds of aid
contributed in the last five years mr
speaker
dear star mr speaker who says the
system's very robust in relation to arms
sales it can't be that robust
the government lost a court case just
two years ago in relation to arms sales
the truth is the uk is increasingly
isolated in selling arms to saudi arabia
despite what's happening in yemen
despite saudi arabia's human rights
record
and the brutal murder of journalist
jamal khashoggi
a murder the us has concluded was
approved by the saudi crown prince
so i have to ask what will it take for
the prime minister
to suspend arms sales to saudi arabia
speaker we've could condemn the murder
of jamal
khashoggi we continue to call for a full
invest investigation into the causes
of his death and indeed we have already
sanctioned 20 people
mr speaker in saudi arabia and i repeat
the
the point that i have made that the uk
government continues to follow the
consolidated guidance of which by the
way mr speaker was set up
by the labour party
mr speaker to make matters worse the
government decided this week to halve
international aid to yemen harvard
the u.n has said that yemen faces the
worst famine the world has seen for
decades
and the secretary general said on monday
that cutting aid would be
in his words a death sentence for the
people of yemen
how on earth can the prime minister
justifying selling arms to saudi arabia
and cutting aid to people starving in
yemen
uh mr speaker it is under this
government that we have
increased to aid spending uh to the
highest proportion
uh in uh the history of our country and
yes
uh it is true that current uh
straightened circumstances which i'm
sure
the people of this country understand
mean that temporally we must
reduce uh aid spending but that does not
obscure the fact mr speaker that when it
comes to our duty to the people
of yemen we continue to step up to the
plate a contribution of 214 million
pounds
for this financial year there are very
few other countries in the world mr
speaker that have such a record that is
setting such an example
in spending and supporting uh the people
of yemen
this week the government halved our
international aid to yemen
if this is what the prime minister
thinks global britain should look like
he should think again and if he doesn't
believe me he doesn't like it from me or
the un
secretary general he should listen to
his own mps
just this morning the conservative mp
for bournemouth said
cutting support to starving children is
not what global britain should be about
it undermines the very idea of the uk as
a nation to be respected
on the global stage and the honourable
member for sutton coalfield said this
this was
unconscionable will the prime minister
now do the right thing
and reconsider this urgently
mr speaker i repeat we've given a
billion pounds since the conflict began
we're in support of un resolutions this
year
we're contributing another 214 a million
pounds to support the people of yemen
there are very few other countries in
the world mr speaker that have that kind
of record i think in these tough
straightened circumstances
uh bearing in mind the immense cost of
the kobe that epidemic that has affected
our country i think the people of this
country
should be very very proud of what we are
doing
[Music]
mr speaker britain should be a moral
force for good in the world
but just as the us is stepping up the uk
is stepping back
if the prime minister and chancellor are
so determined to press ahead
with their manifesto breaking cuts to
international aid
cutting the budget to 0.5 they should at
least put that to a vote in this house
will you have the courage to do so prime
minister
mr speaker we are going to get on with
our agenda
of delivering for the people of this
country and spending
more than virtually any other country in
the world by the way spending more
still than virtually any other country
in the g7 on aid it's a record i think
of which this country can be proud given
the difficulties that this country faces
mr speaker i think that the people of
this country
will think that we've got our priorities
right
he can't work out mr speaker what his
priorities are one minute
uh he's backing uh us on the roadmap the
next week
he's turning his back on us uh one one
well
he can't even be but he can't he can't
even address a question on the issues of
the hour he's gonna have a
he could have asked anything about the
coronavirus pandemic mr speaker instead
he's consecrated his questions uh he's
consecrated questions entirely
to the interests of the people of yemen
mr speaker
we are and we are doing everything we
can to support the people of yemen given
the constraints
that we face we're getting on mr speaker
with a cautious
but irreversible roadmap to freedom
which i hope that he will support
and very shortly mr speaker you will be
hearing a budget for recovery i think i
already know most of it dr liam fox
thank you mr speaker my right honourable
friend will be aware that when
devolution was established
in scotland there was no separate
scottish civil service created
we have a uk civil service with uk
ministerial oversight given the turmoil
in scottish politics will he then
confirm
that any civil servants who feel
pressurized to behave
inappropriately have a mechanism to seek
redress
beyond the ministers to whom they are
immediately answerable
uh of course i thank my normal friend of
course we will
uh support all uh civil servants by the
way i thank
them for their work up and down uh the
country
uh that they've done uh throughout the
the pandemic and i think
uh everybody in this house would agree
that now is the time
really for our civil service to focus on
working
together uh to build back together
uh rather than build back better
together rather than
on measures that might divide our
country mr speaker
now come to the leader of the s p in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister on the terrible atrocity three
years ago in the
town of salisbury mr speaker
the situation in yemen has been called
the world's
worst humanitarian crisis
100 000 people have been killed
16.2 million are at risk of starvation
2.3 million children prime minister
at death's door facing acute
malnutrition the uk government's
response isn't one of compassion
instead it is to impose cuts that's what
you're doing prime minister
a 50 cut to international
aid to yemen a move that the un chief
antonio guterres
has described as a death sentence
since the start of the war the tories
have shamefully backed the saudi regime
through billions of pounds of arms sales
and support despite
evidence of war crimes and of the
targeting of civilians
well the prime minister confirmed
today's budget will force through the
devastating cuts
to international aid speaker
anybody listening to this uh debate uh
will have heard me say that this country
this government uh in the last five
years has given one billion pounds
to support the people of yemen i can
tell him that on monday
mr speaker in case he thinks there's any
uh diminution of rf it's on monday
we're going to provide cash support to
1.5 million
of the most vulnerable yemeni households
support
400 health clinics and treat 75 000
cases
of severe malnutrition mr speaker that
is the continuing effort
of the british people and the british
government to help the people of yemen
in blackfood the reality mr speaker is a
50
cut to yemen aid at a time of a global
pandemic
the coronavirus has hit poor and
vulnerable countries the hardest
threatening decades of hard-won gains
whilst exacerbating
existing inequalities during his
leadership race
the prime minister made a commitment to
stand by 0.7
for aid spending a position he
reaffirmed in june last year
at that very dispatch box what followed
was yet another u-turn another broken
promise why is the prime minister
breaking his own manifesto commitment
and why are his government
breaking the promises they made to the
world's poorest
yeah mr speaker i think most people in
this country will know
that the government has given 280
billion pounds
uh to support the people uh the economy
the livelihoods the businesses
up and down the whole of the united
kingdom and that is a as you will hear
from the chancellor mr speaker
placed uh strains on our public finances
meantime we continue to do everything we
possibly can
to support the people of yemen including
by the way through a
massive vaccination program to which the
people of this country
have contributed million pounds the
second biggest
contributor in the world mr speaker
mr speaker the prime minister will know
from his time working in the black
country
how important our green spaces and green
belt are
will he make sure that dudley council
and amerandi street
have the powers and the resources they
need to ensure development is on ground
field
rather than valuable green spaces and
make sure that local people's voices
are clearly heard and taken into account
including where the proposed development
is across local authority borders liking
the surrounding
green belt to dudley center indeed mr
speaker we will protect our green belt
uh
our vital green belt and uh which it
constitutes
i think 12.4 percent of our of our land
uh but we can build our homes as my well
my own
friend rightly suggests uh 300 000 them
on brownfield sites
across the country let's send to sir
jeffrey donaldson
sir jeffrey and mr speaker we are now in
the third month of the northern ireland
hunger fast approaching the end of the
uh three-month race period
and the prime minister will be aware of
the disruption that the protocol is
causing
uh to trade between great britain and
northern ireland and the damage it's
doing to the stability of the political
institutions established under the
belfast agreement
what action does the prime minister
intend to take to deliver on his promise
that he would protect northern ireland's
position within the uk
internal market and provide us with
unfettered access to goods
from great britain mr speaker the
position of
the northern ireland within the uk
internal market is uh rock solid and
guaranteed
uh we are making sure uh that we
underscore that with some temporary
operational
uh easings uh in order to protect
uh the uh uh protect the market in some
areas
uh such as food supplies uh pending
further discussions
with the eu and i as i've said i think
to the right honourable to the uh
gentleman
and his colleagues we leave nothing off
the table in order to ensure that we get
this right
mr speaker our british vaccine finished
in wokhart
in wrexham has shown the globe exactly
what the uk
can achieve in wrexham we have the milo
hospital
colleague cambria glendore university
and an industrial estate
bristling with smes we're close to the
midlands and the north west
would the prime minister agree with me
that now is the time for our young
people
to look at careers and aspire to careers
in stern healthcare
and wrexham is the hub that can take us
forward
my honourable friend is completely right
i thank her by the way again for her
amazing service in the
uh in the nhs uh in in wrexham and her
returning to the
to the front line and actually it was in
wrexham at workheart
uh that i met a young female scientist
mr speaker who are helping to make the
the vaccine that is not only going to
free our country we hope
uh from the captivity of kovid but help
to liberate the entire world it was
wonderful to see it happening in wrexham
we want to see many more
young female scientists growing up in
that part of the world
let's head to graham morris graham
thank you mr speaker i'd like to ask
about an important domestic issue
the system of the property tax in
england is broken
council tax places an unfair burden on
people with people living in the poorest
communities
without generating the revenues needed
to fund global services
so does the prime minister agree that a
proportional property tax
as proposed by the fair share campaign
would create a transparent property
taxation system
generate revenues local government needs
under
the tax burden on hard-pressed families
across the country
including in my constituency of
easington
uh mr speaker with great respect to the
honourable member what the
uh country needs are councillors that
uh charge you less whilst delivering
better services
and if you look across the country you
can see that it's overwhelmingly
conservative run
uh councils uh that that do that uh mr
speaker
uh the uh ronald mcdonald after opposite
last and mr
westminster they kept council taxes
though uh in camden
uh where he lives it's three times as
high that's the difference
mr speaker so david last friday my
constituent mr luke bellfield who was
aged just 18
was stabbed to death just a few miles
from his family home this has been
horrendous for his
family and his friends who've been left
behind and my heart goes out to them all
what more does my right honourable
friend think that the police
society and parliament can do to make
sure that there never will in the future
be such senseless murders again
mr speaker i sympathize very much with
luke's family and
his friends and uh there's nothing i can
say to
to to alleviate their loss
but what we are doing mr speaker is uh
recruiting many more police officers to
fight crime
uh running up the counter lines drugs
gangs
wherever we can and setting out plans to
keep serious sexual and violent
offenders uh behind bars for longer and
like
i could tell the house uh that we've now
got six thousand six hundred and twenty
of our target uh extra twenty thousand
police already recruited
a trick ready mr speaker we know that
the prime minister is the proud leader
of a british
nationalist party and he says that his
no to another independence referendum
scotland is final
so why are his colleagues in scotland
distributing leaflets that say a vote
for the tories
is a vote to stop an independence
referendum if a vote for the british
nationalist tories in scotland must be
accepted as a legitimate vote
against a referendum surely a vote for
the snp in me
must be respected as a mandate for
putting scotland's future
in scotland's hands yes i'd like you to
hear a sort of uh
acceptance there that he's running a
nationalist uh party if that's what if
that's what if that's what
that's what he if that's what he was uh
what he was saying because i'm afraid i
agree
i agree with that they're not in respect
of of the whole of this country
uh but i think most people will think it
extraordinary uh that
they're talking about another referendum
uh the labor chief whip is nodding quite
rightly
uh when uh when actually what the what
the people of this country want to see
is us working together as one united
kingdom without further constitutional
upheaval to get through the pandemic and
build that better
sarah thank you mr speaker and can i
firstly just say how great it was
to welcome my right honourable friend to
akron last week and i'm sure the prime
minister will join me in thanking both
the staff
and pupils at akronton academy for
making our visit such a welcoming one
as you'll know mr speaker my
constituency but was at the heart of the
first
industrial revolution and we're ready to
lead in the new
green industrial revolution and level up
once and for all
so on that note will my right honourable
friend commit supporting my campaign
to rejuvenate our high streets and town
centres across hanbon and hasland
mr speaker i congratulate my honourable
friend on her campaign uh it was great
to be
in akrington and i hope that she'll be
hearing uh even more shortly from my run
on friend the chancellor about what we
can do
uh to support uh the towns fund and
other measures to help accrington and
places across the whole country mr
speaker
we're now heading up to emmy callahan oh
no i do welcome back again
good to see you amy callahan
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank um you and members across the
house including the prime minister for
your well wishes during my illness
mr speaker the prime minister had
previously guaranteed there was no
threat to the erasmus scheme as a result
of brexit
we now know that charities such as stan
international and my constituency
who participates in the program are set
to lose 96 of their funding
as a result of the uk government's
decision to pull the plug on erasmus
plus
can the prime minister guarantee that
charities will receive match funding
under the new turing scheme
while he agreed to meet with me and
representatives from stan international
to ensure no young person in eastern
partner
gets left behind as a result of brexit
i i'm sure i speak for everybody when i
say how much i welcome
uh the honorable lady back to pmq's it's
great great to see her back
uh mr speaker and i do i do give her
this assurance that i do i think the
touring scheme
will be better and it will deliver
exactly what uh she wants because i
think if there was a criticism of the
erasmus schemes it tended to favor
uh higher income households we will do
everything uh that we can
uh with the turing scheme uh to reach
out to uh give
uh opportunity to people from
disadvantaged backgrounds that is
what we intend to do
thank you mr speaker my right honourable
friend has taken a strong
personal interest in the tragic story of
my constituent harry dunn
so can i ask him will he please continue
to do everything in his power to
reassure
tim and charlotte harry's parents and
all their family
that he will try to persuade president
biden
to deliver justice for harry
i thank my right honourable friend and
she's completely right to continue to
raise the case
of uh harry dunn and
and we sympathize deeply with his family
it's a case that
uh we continue to raise at the highest
level and i know that
uh my right honorable friend the foreign
secretary has only just raised it
uh now with uh with tony blinken uh us
secretary of state
i said to beth winter beth
thank you mr speaker from the canada
where my constituency of cana valley is
located has the third highest corporate
death rate in the uk
due mainly to equality poverty and
chronic underfunding
this uk government has an appalling
record on providing wales with even a
fair share of uk spending
let alone the funded needed to level up
11 years of tourist steady cuts
destroyed the capacity of our public
services to withstand the pandemic
and now he plans to bypass the
democratic structures in wales
my constituent lyndon has a question for
the prime minister
what will it take for him to stop
ignoring the south wales valleys
mr speaker i i'm afraid i disagree
profoundly with the
uh with the implication of what she she
is saying and indeed with
what her constituent linda uh is by
implication
uh asking because uh this government
continues to give massive support
through
uh the barnet formula and elsewhere i
think the uh through barnet alone it's
2.4
billion pounds and there is now more
coming uh mr speaker
uh through the uh the levelling up fund
and other
uh and other means and it's thanks to
the uk government that the furlough
scheme has supported 3
400 jobs in her constituency alone
mr speaker and that is one of the
advantages of the united kingdom
let's go to andrew bowie andrew
thank you very much mr speaker only this
week the government once again
demonstrated its commitment to the
energy industry jobs in the northeast of
scotland
as a whole with over 30 million pounds
committed to creating a green
energy transition zone in a global
underwater hub but with my right humber
friend therefore
go further and support this most vital
industry
vital to developing the energy
technologies the future based he will
agree in the greatest part of the
country
transitioning to net zero with a
long-awaited energy transition deal
which will help transform the oil
capital of europe into the green
energy center of the world
well mr speak i really congratulate my
honourable friend on his uh last minute
lobbying he's only got a few minutes to
wait
uh before he may hear something to his
advantage let's go to color lockout
caller thank you mr speaker
prime minister in an interview with
sophie ridge broadcast on the 8th of
december
2019 you pledged there would be no
checks on goods going from ni to gb
or from gb to ni while this has proven
more challenging
to deliver and practice would you wish
to take this opportunity to encourage
ministers
in northern ireland to do all they can
or other
or order unfortunately i'm not
responsible and you is not
something that we should be using
my humble apologies can you make this an
aspiration to reality and to ensure they
act in accordance with section 46
of the united kingdom internal market
act 2020
which stresses the importance of
facilitating
the free flow of goods between great
britain and northern ireland
yes mr speaker i certainly can do that
and as i said
in answer to another uh right honourable
gentleman from her
party we leave nothing on off the table
in order uh to make sure that we get
that done and there is
unfettered access nigb and gbni
let's head to andrew percy andrew
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
has been a good friend of east culture
and northern lincolnshire and he will be
aware that the humber
is the biggest trading uh estuary in the
country and contains the uk
deport but will i can i encourage him
therefore to look at the humber freeport
closely and also favorably as it
contains sites in whole
ghoul grimsby and the skuntop steelworks
which are really important for this
region
he's absolutely right mr speaker my
honorable friend is
is uh has mounted an excellent uh
campaign
and uh the uh chancellor myron from the
chance will be saying
more about that a little shortly okay
thank you mr speaker hs2
reduces journey times from monster
airport to london
from 2 hours 24 minutes to 59
minutes with the carbon capture that we
would generate
and the increased capacity to the west
coast mainline can i ask the prime
minister mr speaker
what prevents governments from putting
shovels in the ground in the north now
mr speaker the the answer to that is as
anybody knows who
gets a project done on uh their home or
whether or wherever
if you if you start again uh midway
through you i'm afraid you
you greatly multiply uh the cost uh but
we're gonna go as fast as we possibly
can final question donnie cooper
thank you mr speaker the last time the
uk hosted the g7 in 2013
the then prime minister launched the
social impact investment task force
to catalyze a market for private capital
seeking social
outcomes as well as financial returns
and this country now leads the world
in the development of financial
innovations for public good
so will my right honourable friend
confirm that the social impact social
investment tax relief
which was launched after that summit
will continue beyond april
and will he use this year's g7 to
trumpet to the world
the benefit of social investment social
enterprise and the social economy in
general
my my honorable friend has long been a
campaigner for the wonderful benefits of
social enterprise uh when i visited some
of his own
and uh if he just waits a little bit
longer he'll receive an update on social
investment
tax relief mr speaker i'm suspending the
house for three minutes to enable the
necessary arrangements for the next
business to be made order